well we are working to answer any
questions you might have about getting
your 12 to 15 year olds vaccinated after
the fda authorized and the cdc
recommended pfizer vaccinations for this
age group
there is a post on our facebook if you'd
like to take part in our discussion
earlier in the hour dr kerry weejay
singha the owner and medical director of
siena pediatrics answered several of
your questions
and to follow up on the subject now dr
kerry are there any considerations
parents should keep in mind
for getting the vaccine for their kids
if their child takes any prescribed
medications
yes there are children that have heart
conditions
pulmonary conditions immunosuppressant
conditions
they should be speaking to their
pediatrician and their specialist to
make sure that they're not on medication
that
would be contraindicated in the covenant
vaccine all right
another important thing i know you
wanted to get out there you do want to
see
a certain window in between the covid
vaccine
and some of the vaccines kids need to
get before they head back to school
correct
actually that was just changed late last
night um the ap
and the acip has come together and
to increase the vaccination rates that
have actually been down
quite a lot in the pandemic we are now
allowed to give the cobit vaccine
in addition to the other routine
vaccines at the visits
wow that is an update from last we spoke
just last week okay thank you very much
for that
finally now that this age group is
eligible what fears do you want to
address with any parents who may be
hesitant
you know i think a lot of parents are
still again afraid of the
this newness of the vaccine i hear this
every day in the office
um i i remind them that you know and
sometimes they've actually received the
vaccine
as well that it's the same safety
as well as side effects that they've had
the children the teenagers when i
question them they actually want to get
the vaccine
they're excited they want to get back to
school they want to be outside
hanging out with their friends so
it would be very interesting to see a
poll of the teenagers
because i think a good majority of them
really want to get this vaccine and
to resume their normal life all right
thank you so much for your time
throughout this hour dr kerry j sinha we
greatly appreciate it and of course we
look forward to talking to you in the
near future as well take care thank you